[Music]
hi it's mark ellis and welcome to
another episode of rt essentials this
week we're talking the reason for the
season that is the halloween franchise
and it's big bad michael myers
what has made audiences demand new
movies in the john carpenter classic
franchise while so many others freddie
jason pinhead leatherface have been
consigned to the slasher filled history
books with 11 movies to date and two
more on the way halloween is a franchise
that stood the test of time with at
least one installment in every decade
since the 1970s and while michael myers
may not be the most charismatic or
quippy of boogeyman he is the granddaddy
of them all and with the upcoming
halloween kills and halloween ends he's
proving that an old babysitter obsessed
serial killer can still learn some new
tricks
and as always the spoiler alert is on
don't touch that dial we're about to go
deep into halloween on this week's rt
essentials
halloween
he can't kill the boogeyman
[Music]
get in there come on tommy now lock the
door
it started as a sequel pitch in the mid
70s john carpenter approached writer
director bob clark and asked for his
permission to write a follow-up to his
film black christmas the script
eventually evolved into its own project
halloween with co-writer deborah hill
coming up with all the teen's dialogue
and carpenter focusing on dr samuel
loomis's speeches and boy did dr loomis
love to talk i met him 15 years ago i
was told there was nothing left
no reason
no
conscience no understanding and even the
most rudimentary sense of life or death
of good or evil right or wrong which
contrasted nicely with the hulking
menace of michael myers a mute
psychopath who murdered a sister on
halloween when he was six years old and
15 years later breaks out of an asylum
to stalk a babysitter and her friends in
hattenfield illinois in meyers carpenter
set out to create a monster that
audiences should never be able to relate
to his name is only said once in the
entire film and the credits list him as
the shape not only does he not talk we
never see his face instead he's
outfitted himself in a bleached out
captain kirk mask yeah most people don't
know this but michael myers huge trekkie
fan
to play laurie strode the young
babysitter who manages to go toe-to-toe
with myers and survive carpenter cast
jamie lee curtis as an homage to his
favorite director curtis's mother janet
lee starred in alfred hitchcock's psycho
hello help me
can you please help me
please
can't you hear me
oh god
[Music]
making her movie debut at 19 curtis was
the only actual teenager in the film but
certainly made an impression going on to
play laurie seven more times if we
include the upcoming double feature and
becoming one of the most recognizable
final girls in history despite some
dubious expository work how and when did
michael myers ever learn how to drive a
car why was that hardware store even
selling masks halloween was a smash hit
working off of a budget of around three
hundred thousand dollars it grows 47
million at the united states box office
making it one of the most successful
independent films of all time and
opening the door for a
multi-generational family saga to rival
that of the corleones
halloween too
[Music]
[Applause]
in 1981 three years after the originals
blockbuster success halloween two came
to theaters the sequel picks up right
where the first one left off it's still
halloween night when michael shows up to
the hospital where laurie is
recuperating after the confrontation in
order to preserve the continuity jamie
lee curtis had to wear a wig to hide her
newly short hair
[Music]
having turned down the chance to direct
the sequel carpenter agreed to stay on
as executive producer and writer as a
way to recoup the money he felt he was
owed from the original picture working
with only a grudge and a nightly
six-pack of heineken carpenter said he
made some bad decisions with the story
and called the final product quote an
abomination and a terrible movie this is
why you should never do movies out of
spite people
still halloween 2 was not without its
merits it introduced that laurie was
actually michael myers younger sister a
bit of retconning that would remain
canon until david gordon-green's 2018
halloween reboot which posits at the
events of halloween two through
resurrection never took place so to
recap laurie wasn't his sister and that
she was a sister then she wasn't his
sister anymore forget it michael this is
halloweentown wait lori
that is the exact same mask that's used
in the first halloween film the reason
it looks different is that the original
michael nick castle kept it folded in
his back pocket during takes after which
he had spent several years sitting under
the bed of debra hill a heavy smoker
which yellowed the rubber the new
michael dick warlock was shorter and
stockier than his predecessor and had a
bigger head causing the mask to mold
differently with his face less
explainable is michael going from being
a dark brunette to a strawberry blonde
arguably michael's hair was a bigger
identifying trait than laurie's but no
she's the one that got stuck with a wig
come on castle asked the producers to
keep the mask as a souvenir thinking
this would be the last film they let him
this led to a blanket rule going forward
no one was allowed to keep costumes or
props from the set it's also why the
mask would look notably different
starting with halloween four
it is time michael
what about halloween three
yes i'm so glad you asked
halloween three season of the witch
[Music]
one year after halloween two universal
pictures decided you know what who needs
michael myers and got rid of the main
antagonist tent pole propping up the
entire franchise in favor of a totally
original story
where is she
1982's halloween three season of the
witch was to be set up for an annual
anthology series which would reboot with
a new premise each installment think
american horror story which isn't
necessarily a bad thing but if you're
showing up to the theaters expecting to
see michael myers and you instead get
this zany story about subliminal
messaging and tv commercials and an
irish druid cult manufacturing halloween
masks that turn kids into bug people you
might understand why audiences felt the
way they did about halloween 3.
[Laughter]
in the decades following its release
season of the which has gained an
appreciation and a cult following as a
standalone it's so bonkers it borders on
genius but at the time it saw a crushing
defeat at the box office and all but
necessitating that follow-up films have
michael myers somewhere not only in the
movie but in the subtitle originally
carpenter tapped joe dante to direct the
film who in turn hired actor
screenwriter nigel neal to pen halloween
3 as a horror comedy dante soon left the
project but producers liked the idea of
a totally original script so it stayed
unfortunately producers and ultimately
carpenter and new director tommy lee
wallace didn't understand that the goofy
plot was supposed to be satirical and
rewrote large chunks to be more
self-serious and gory
but perhaps my favorite piece of
unsubstantiated trivia about season of
the witch is that the film was in part
inspired by critic rex reed's review of
halloween 2 in which he claimed if they
make a halloween 3 i'll turn in my press
card season of the witch would fail in
this respect as well which is why again
it's usually not a good idea to make
movies out of spite please stop it stop
it now turn it off turn it off
stop it
stop it stop it stop it stop it
stop it
stop it
but halloween like michael myers himself
or itself just refused to die leading to
halloween four the return of michael
myers
michael
[Music]
with 1988's halloween 4 the return of
michael myers the franchise had a major
problem it needed to return to the
original story but curtis no longer
wanted to be involved this is why the
film begins with laurie strode already
dead killed off in an off-screen car
accident before the movie starts leaving
her young daughter jamie to defeat uncle
michael
carpenter originally wanted the film to
address more supernatural elements to
explain why michael myers could suddenly
you know just put his hands into people
like silly putty but canon producers
ultimately rejected the treatment
written by carpenter to make a more
traditional slasher film this led to the
first time carpenter would have no
involvement with one of the halloween
films
[Music]
you can still see remnants of
carpenter's draft which centered heavily
on haddonfield as its own character in a
plot that can only be described as half
the town the dreaded sundown and half
footloose the return sees the holiday of
halloween abandoned hat and field
causing teens to revolt and michael to
come back and teach them all the true
meaning of how to dance um murder
the return of michael meyer's infamous
ending saw jaime revealed to be a baby
michael incarnate killing her adopted
mother after evading michael in a
labyrinth-like laundry shoot playing
jaime actress danielle harris confessed
that she believed the next film was
going to have her as the big bad but
having been spooked by the disappointing
turnout of the third film producers
turned michael myers into the energizer
bunny no matter how many times he took
six shots to the chest in close range he
just had to keep going and going and
going now
[Music]
halloween five the revenge of michael
myers
[Music]
one year after the return of michael
myers yes are you seeing a pattern here
a new halloween film arrived but while
1989's the revenge of michael myers was
on every poster promoting halloween five
the subtitle was nowhere in the actual
film as mentioned earlier revenge
retconned the ending of return to kill
her adopted mom a year later a mutant
traumatized jaime lives in an
institution under the care of dr loomis
sound familiar stop the rage
the rage
you don't need that
[Music]
maybe the craziest twist in the movie
was the decision to not make jamie a
killer on a par with her uncle this
would mark the second instance of a
sequel majorly retconning events we'd
seen in the prior film after the opening
of halloween two showed a different
version of the original ending of
halloween donald pleasant for one was
reportedly super pissed about jamie not
stepping into her uncle's sizable shoes
and becoming the next gen bad seed
michael myers audiences well they
weren't thrilled either halloween five
had the lowest box office of any entry
in the franchise national guard will
take him to a maximum security facility
but he'll stay till the day he dies
never die
having been portrayed by george p wilber
in four michael was again recast now 39
year old don shanks was playing the 32
year old michael myers which doesn't
seem like that big of a difference but
set the stage for some real age gaps in
the subsequent sequel when michael does
a drive-by of the school dance it was
originally supposed to be in a ronald
reagan mask this was cut as the studio
didn't want their slasher film to come
off as too political or to coincide with
the movie coming out a few years later
point break
halloween six the curse of michael myers
[Music]
it would be a long six years before
halloween six the curse of michael myers
arrived in 1995 in part due to studio
reluctance over the poor turnout for the
previous film and partly because it was
an incredibly troubled production
the curse of michael myers wasn't the
original subtitle to the film but the
nickname used on set that just happened
to stick because of the bad luck
surrounding the movie in one tragic
example siri staple and legendary actor
donald pleasence passed away during the
shoot and a stand-in was required for dr
wilmus's remaining scenes with a
ridiculous cult subplot this is the one
where it's officially made canon that
michael is meta-human so at least i
finally explained why he was impervious
to all those bullets and the low box
office of its predecessor the curse of
michael myers had no reason to open as
big as it did getting the largest
opening weekend of any film in the
franchise right up until 2018's
halloween
walks amongst us brother
he's come back curse was blessed in one
respect it was the debut of film actor
paul rudd though his big break clueless
arrived in theaters a few months earlier
the ant-man star had shot halloween
prior to the teen comedy playing the
role of grown-up tommy doyle and he
still looks the same exact age today
mike
you've won
he's yours
speaking of age the gap between myers
and the man who played him only grew by
this film michael's supposed to be in
his mid-30s while george wilbur the
actor playing the shape was 54 years old
[Music]
halloween h2o 20 years later
i thought
1998's halloween h2o which is you really
h20 but h2o is just fun to say saw the
return of laurie strode and with it a
clever meta approach to the genre that
had become popular after wes craven's
scream in fact screams writer kevin
williamson also wrote h2o more than one
version in fact h2o was never supposed
to be about laurie but when jamie lee
curtis expressed interest to coming back
into the franchise williamson rewrote
the entire script to focus on miss
strode now a private school teacher and
her teenage son what the [ __ ] do you
think you're doing mom i'm really
uncomfortable with you saying that well
then don't put me in the position john
do you know what day it is
michael myers is dead bringing it back
around curtis's mother janet lee
actually does make an appearance in this
film marking only the second time in
which mother and daughter share the
screen
the first fittingly was in john
carpenter's the fog which also marked
lee's last on-screen role prior h2o
we've all had bad things happen to us
the trick is to concentrate on today
what do i know
you just
take care of yourself okay
thank you very much i'll see you monday
oh miss tate uh
happy halloween
carpenter must have been thrilled to
find that the franchise finally bagged
his inspiration for laurie's casting
only to be in a film that he had nothing
to do with
jamie lee curtis's nickname for actor
chris durand who played michael myers
during filming was shapy it's neither
here nor there it's just one thing to
say hey shafee
you're getting some crap services shafie
in the third major retcon of the
franchise h2o treats the original first
two halloween movies as canon so michael
is still wary's brother but ignores
everything from halloween's three
through resurrection so ari never had a
daughter and never died in a car
accident this was done to simplify the
plot and for that we all just want to
give h2o our sincerest gratitude thank
you so very much
[Music]
but after a pretty definitive
decapitation of michael myers what
choice did the next film have but to
bring him back by reimagining
yet again the events of this film here
it comes
hello michael halloween resurrection
[Music]
if h2o was an attempt to make michael
meta 2002's halloween resurrection tried
to make him trending the story revolved
around two reality tv producers played
by buster rhymes and tyra banks who
convinced a bunch of college age kids to
spend a night at the myers residence
equipped with only handheld cameras that
broadcast their every move to the world
wide web
[Music]
[Applause]
after dispatching lorry in the first
five minutes of the movie michael goes
home to kick his feet up only to find
these unwanted guests laying in his bed
it's blair witch meets the three bears
[Music]
charlie what the [ __ ] you've been there
man don't you know we've been looking
all over this moment for you and why the
hell you dressed like me anyway i ain't
telling you to be michael myers i'm
playing michael myers once again neither
jamie lee curtis nor john carpenter
wanted much to do with the film jamie
lee only agreed because she was under
contract but had negotiated a clause in
which her character would be killed off
in the opening scene carpenter meanwhile
almost coined a term when he called his
reaction to it cringe they both later
went on record calling resurrection a
joke there was another returning face
this time around director rick rosenthal
was back in the mix after his stint on
halloween 2. new to the ensemble was
stunned actor brad laurie playing
michael myers in this installment a
lifelong horror fan rory was originally
slated to play jason in freddy vs jason
until directors decided he was too short
to tower over robert england
had the series not been rebooted in the
following film due to massively
disappointing box office grosses laurie
had said that he'd have liked to
continue slaughtering unsuspecting teens
as michael myers in the movie not in
real life
trick or treat
[ __ ] several different endings
to this film were shot and the original
plan was to distribute them in different
theaters a lot clue so you got to go
multiple times to catch them all that's
a great idea oh but the plan was
eventually scrapped and became a bonus
feature for the blu-ray and dvds instead
mark that down as two bye
halloween
again
it wasn't until rob zombie's 2007
halloween that fans saw an official
reboot inspired by carpenter's advice to
make the story his own zombies was a
complete reimagining of the saga
focusing more on the story of michael
myers childhood zombie originally went
to the studio pitching two different
films a prequel film and a more faithful
reboot of the original both ideas were
shot down and eventually a middle ground
was reached which is why half the movie
was about meyers's child years and half
was a condensed version of the original
halloween film
what happened
the film starred tyler mayne as the
adult michael malcolm mcdowell is dr
loomis scout taylor compton as laurie
strode and danielle harris yes worry's
daughter jaime from the curse and the
return as friend annie beckett i'm joe
grisley
at six foot nine uwf wrestler taiwan is
the tallest michael to date and this
last one is just super important to me
personally this marks the first time
michael myers would not be able to
spontaneously drive a car having been
locked up his entire adult life thus
fixing my biggest problem with the
entire halloween franchise thank you rob
zombie michael myers no longer on the
highway as a demon speeding
halloween two
again
rob zombie's halloween was supposed to
be a one-off but its success all but
guaranteed a sequel enter halloween 2.
it's a movie rob zombie had stated on
multiple occasions he'd never make but
changed his tune when the studio
greenlitted anyway in zombie not wanting
anyone else to ruin his vision
reluctantly agreed to write and direct
with this film tyler mayne became the
first actor ever to play michael myers
in consecutive films stuntman george
wilbur played the shape in both the
return and the curse of michael myers
but didn't get the role for the revenge
of michael myers which was sandwiched in
between in a deviation from the original
film laurie's friend and daughter of
sheriff beckett survived the events of
the first film and made a return and
with that actress danielle harris
officially tied jamie lee curtis for
most appearances in the franchise a
record curtis then broke when she would
go on to star in 2018's halloween
halloween 2 which only vaguely resembles
the original sequel for the first 15
minutes before jumping a year ahead into
a new plot saw a new turn for the dr
loomis character than we'd ever seen
before now on a book tour touting his
intimate knowledge of the serial killer
he helped raise this egotistical and
bombastic loomis was inspired when
zombies started watching dr phil
oh i want to be there in that room
your monster killed her
you butchered my baby back up it's all
right everyone just calm down calm down
all right he's under control
halloween again
again 2018. say something
[Music]
in 2018 the buzz was in david gordon
green director of stoner comedies like
pineapple express and your highness had
brought jamie lee curtis back into the
fold with a new halloween film aptly
titled halloween and yes for anyone
keeping score this is the third movie
with just halloween as the title
co-written with longtime collaborator
danny mcbride it marked the
re-re-re-return
of laurie strode though as mentioned
earlier this iteration erased everything
after the initial halloween so larry was
now just a random babysitter that was
unfortunate enough to bump into michael
some 40 years ago
now estranged from her daughter and
granddaughter and living off the grid
laurie's paranoia gets to say i told you
so when myers escapes from smith's grove
institution
yet again and comes after her extended
family this time though glory is
prepared with a high-end prepper's worth
of booby traps artillery and secret
combustible basements i do not want to
play in that house
curtis hadn't planned on doing another
halloween film but was convinced by
actor jake gyllenhaal who she calls her
unofficial godson to meet with green
also returning to the franchise was nick
castle the og michael myers who finally
is age-appropriate this time it marks
something of a family reunion as the two
were joined by malik akkad the son of
original producer mustafa akkad john
carpenter who signed on as executive
producer and composer as well as
universal pictures for distribution and
that's saying a lot because the last
time universal was attached to a
halloween movie it was season of the
witch
[Music]
final fact that may be redundant at this
point but here we go halloween was
originally intended to be the final
installment in the franchise until the
film's success opened the door to
surprise surprise two more sequels but
you guys they promise they swear cross
their heart this is the last time so
bunker your seat belt and hide those
kitchen knives because the saga of
michael myers and laurie strode isn't
over halloween kills and halloween ends
in july 2019 both halloween kills and
halloween ends were simultaneously
announced by blumhouse set to debut a
year apart both films were delayed a
year due to cobit 19. you and allison
should not have to keep running
evil
dies
tonight the films are intended to be the
end of the franchise for the time being
does anybody really believe that and
curtis has stated this will most likely
be the last time she plays the role of
warri but you know never say never
especially when a guy named michael
myers is involved nancy stevens and
charles cipher are going to reprise
their roles from the original film as
nurse marion and sheriff beckett kyle
richards will also reprise her role as
an adult lindsay wallace and the role of
adult tommy doyle will be played by
anthony michael hall paul rudd was
originally approached to reprise his
role of adult tommy doyle but couldn't
do it thanks to scheduling conflicts
filmmakers have teased that halloween
kills will be a more cerebral story
focusing on the effects the murders have
had on the haddenfield residence while
halloween ends will be the largest and
bloodiest film in the franchise which we
now know has a crap ton of movies to its
credit you want your mask
i'm coming for you michael
so there you have it your essential
rundown of all things halloween if you
enjoyed this episode why don't you head
on over to rottentomatoes.com and check
out even more great content about
carpenter's famously freaky franchise
and a lot of other seasonal scares as
well have a happy and safe halloween and
if you're trick-or-treating and there's
a giant shape lumbering behind you just
pick up the pace a little bit that dude
can't walk more than three miles an hour
you'll be fine
[Music]